but the thing is is I was engaged to get
married but it's like do I stay in that
relationship where he's gonna
continuously cheat on me just so that I
can be aware no you don't get points for
almost I didn't ask for points no I'm
just saying that I've been engaged too
but I never got one but my point is is
that do I like for me to get across that
line of like yay I can be married do I
then have to be that submissive that I
then put up with being
but you're not a virgin you weren't a
virgin for him right you had children
we've got children yeah yeah no I'm
saying were you a virgin no no no no no
no no and that's what I'm saying like in
a way we cheat on our husbands by not
saving Purity for them
and we're gonna shame them for cheating
no no I would cheat on us too
would you would you stay in a marriage
if he cheated on you you got kids no not
before yeah hell yeah if you got kids if
you got kids
but it's also then teaching your son
that it's okay to be
he's a blueprint so automatically no no
his dad is constantly I'm not going to
be happy yeah
I haven't told him but at the same time
I'm not going to be me it just looks
like mommy's not happy
don't you think you're in control of
your happiness you don't think it's a
choice yet my choice is to not stay in
that relationship that's going to
continuously cheat on me so I'll be
happy my son has brilliant right but
that's that's what I'm saying so like
you're putting your happiness over
what's best for the kids and that's like
all a while a lot of time having to
happen and that's that's why a lot of
times like men are leaving for the West
because it's like women here like think
it's about us when it's not about us
it's about the family first and and I
know like and the other thing is one out
of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year under
30 like there are men that you could
pick that would be faithful to you but
if you if you go for a guy that's
attractive to you he's going to be
attractive to other women I was gonna
ask you was he a top 20 man
we were both in the military I was like
18 when I'm yeah okay so I'm saying if
you looked at your man he looked at your
man was he the type of man that other
women wanted of course right okay so
what happened is you probably chose a
top 20 man because you were attracted to
him right he was and who is also
attractive to other women a caveat women
find 80 percent of of men that's
unattractive so if you found him
attractive he's probably in the top 20
percent right so so what happens is
there's a top 20 man who's got 80 of
women to choose from right I'm not and
so I'm saying and I'm not condoning what
he's doing I'm just saying if a man is
in a top 20 and he's got 80 of women
throwing in throwing their panties at
him right at some point in time he might
take that option and I'm not saying that
it's right or wrong I'm saying women
generally go for men right the other
women find attractive of course because
you don't go for men who you know work
at Starbucks and they're stacking
shelves generally and you don't go for
those men so what happens is part and
parcel of choosing a guy that other
women like
is that you've got to put up with being
cheap I'm not saying you've got to put
up with it I'm saying
I mean I really honest me as a parent
now in comparison to me as a parent when
I went out because obviously I had
an amazing the the mother that my son
has
now and my ability to give him the calm
from my feminine energy I wouldn't have
been able to do in that relationship so
for me 100 my son gets the best of me
out of that relationship can I can I
just simply say um for the lady with the
Sun
I don't think you'll have to worry about
any influences from outside of of your
husband or anyone else that your son's
gonna learn how to cheat you'll learn
your son will know how to cheat yeah of
course when it gets older when when
women simply offer themselves to it yeah
of course so there's no this is again I
see that as a cope it's like I think my
happiness I got rid of him because yeah
exactly again it comes down to you so it
was actually your personal choice for
your well-being not your sons Not Your
Daughters it was really your I'm sure
so do you I'm just curious do you you
think your happiness is more important
than the family and your son's happiness
my ability to feed into my children
determines my 100 if I my cup's not full
okay then I'm not able to offend my
children
and you don't you don't 100 you don't
and you don't think you control your
emotions in any way not back then no I
was so young I was like in my early 20s
which I understand maybe I was like in
hindsight would you say it was a mistake
being with a 100 no not being with him
leaving him no no he would do that I
would do it at exactly 100 you know
what's interesting is because uh like
even last week I was I was talking about
um I actually watched a tick tock video
and I say it was on Tick Tock but it was
actually a conversation between a man
and a woman who had just divorced her
husband yeah and he was asking her why
did you divorce your husband and she was
saying
he was too
good with money
and this is what she was saying she was
saying he was he lacked a sage
didn't like to spend
you know he was a little bit he was
always talking about oh we gotta say for
a rainy day blah blah blah right and she
left him
because he didn't do the things that
made her happy
but what he was actually doing
was doing that
to secure the family unit right and so
when when a woman says if I'm not happy
then I'll do X Y and Z this men have to
watch I would say men have to really
watch out for women who care about their
happiness over the actual family
structure because that means that
because you know as a woman your
happiness fluctuates from week to week
from day to day from month to month when
there's happiness deep depression
they're two different things but I'm
trying to what I'm trying to say is a
woman is soul led by her emotions right
and a man is more so led by a lot
pragmatic pragmatic right and so we when
a woman says things that oh because I
wasn't happy that's why I left in in my
in my head I don't know about the other
man I'm like red flag
there's happiness and then there's being
like if you're a concert it's not like
I've left at the first cheat like I
didn't just be like yo bye peace out
thanks this is fantastic not at all it
took a lot for me to get to that point
too well I didn't I did not want to be a
single parent again how did you find out
about the cheating
um he had a whole relationship with her
my son was she phoned him and I answered
and we were in and she was having a
whole Affair yeah and she was crying
down the phone saying oh he told me that
these two weren't together and
um yeah anyway I won't go too deep into
it but what did he say about it
he tried to deny it obviously but
you took you took her word over his
she provided me with enough evidence to
prove that that her
um you know truth to it and then
eventually he was sending flowers did
you did you ask him why he cheated
he just says every vagina like it's just
a different vagina that was his response
did you do you believe him yeah yeah
yeah you don't think it was actually
emotional not for no I think with
um he's like so opposite to me he's like
the opposite and he's so pragmatic so
logical so like we see the world isn't
that what attracted you to him
no he's really funny he's really tall as
well no I'm joking I was it
you give it away
to be fair when I met him I was
at war in Iraq and it was [ __ ] 50
degrees and then I I think it was more
the fact that we were both in the
military and so when you're both in the
military you have an understanding of
being in a way for like it there was a
lot of things that went into me ending
up with my son's dad one thing I think I
just want to highlight uh Pearl you had
a guest that was a Pakistani lady who
had uh and her father had an entire
different family in Pakistan that to me
goes to the heart of the the culture and
sort of rooted
um you know values that certain people
from different countries have here is a
lady who's had a husband cheat on her a
couple of times I'm out here's another
lady who had her husband have an entire
different family
with the relationship she didn't know
about it and that's that's the thing
like like Western women were not ride or
dies it's like one problem and we're out
and especially like he didn't even
emotionally cheat how do we expect but
like I don't think you could really
expect him I don't think I don't think
you can expect monogamy if you're not a
virgin like I think you deserve monogamy
if you're a virgin but if you're not
like you're kind of cheating on your
future husband I think I deserve
emotional um stability like in the sense
that it's the lies the gaslighting that
like you know as a woman your intuition
can pick up on certain things and if
you're being gasoline so many times and
you're like am I going crazy is it like
is so for me it's maybe if I even broke
it down even deeper was it the act of
having sex with somebody that hurt me or
was it all the lies and the like the
making me feel like I was crazy
was it like you asking where he was was
it texts
um yeah if you ask a question and they
they there's just little things because
there were so many times that it
happened that it was like it wasn't the
first believe it it wasn't the first
time so what do you think you would have
done if he just told you the truth I'm
gonna start with you've stuck around
still or do you think you still would
have left well I've been in polyamorous
relationships so it's not like like
after as I've got older I've understood
the complexities of men and understood
that sometimes if I'm not able to give
my partner something that he potentially
maybe can seek from somebody else maybe
I'm open to that I'm open to the
conversation but if you take away my
right of choice like choose like I get
to choose whether I want to be like with
like that person and also like when it's
polyamorous it's very open and you know
who that person is and the energies
they're being brought into your home and
stuff after you had your son with him
what if he chose to say look I want this
to be polyamorous now how would you feel
it would have to be a discussion I don't
know because well he's saying I'm I'm
doing this regardless yeah but then
that's not a discussion that's just
that's him telling me something so so
you would have been out then basically
no I'd have the discussion I don't know
how I would have felt in that maybe if
it was probably Emery works both ways so
maybe if I can if it's good for the
goose is good for the Gambler right so
maybe if I can have my emotional
connection that he maybe wasn't giving
me all the Deep conversations maybe I
can get that from somewhere else did you
actually believe that really what you're
saying to me do I believe in what do you
believe that you would have actually
given it a chance
yeah that was like however many years
ago I'm a very different person today
the person you're talking to now is a
very different person to who left
whenever but back then so see you had
this you had your child oh no you would
have left yeah I would have left
so you said it was the light so you said
it was the lies but you know yeah but
he'd already lied at that point you're
talking about was he cheating before you
had had your child listen I said that
before you heard your child
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible